[Music]
we are hearing from the mother of
two-year-old
amari nicholson for the first time since
her boyfriend was
arrested for amari's murder taylor
nicholson has stayed out of the public
eye since her son's body was found this
week
and it's a story many of you have been
following the i-team's vanessa murphy
first broke news of what many feared
police saying the child was murdered
tonight vanessa brings us her interview
with taylor nicholson
the gum is it yummy this is amari
nicholson
he was an innocent soul the
two-year-old's life was cut
short he was always a happy baby metro
police say terrell rhodes admitted to
beating omaree to death
on may 5th this man betrayed me
he hurt me amari's mother taylor
nicholson tells the i-team she showed up
in court friday to follow her now
ex-boyfriend's criminal case
rhodes faces charges including murder on
may 5
rhodes lied to police and said a woman
took amari from their place at the
emerald suites near paradise and twain
while nicholson was out of town the
couple then talked with eight news now
and rhodes shared a similar story what's
really sickening is that people
is making assumptions thinking that
i have something to do with it that i
have heard
manipulated in some way the las vegas
community jumped into action to search
for amari
whatever it takes to bring omaree home
we're just pleading for the public's
help because we don't have any new
information
but four days after that interview with
eight news now
detectives say rhodes confessed to
killing omaree and hiding his body
on wednesday the toddler's remains were
found
my head just fell i was
disappointed i felt betrayed i just felt
my whole insides just fall out the
i-team has learned
one complaint was made to child
protective services alleging neglect
last
june but the allegations were found to
be unsubstantiated and the case was
closed
now on social media nicholson has
received criticism
people raising questions about whether
she had any involvement or knowledge
about amari's death
and at this vigil wednesday night an
event to remember amari turned
to harsh words for the mother you need
to feel the pain at each and every one
of those people standing here today
taylor nicholson says she feels like
public enemy number one
she understands members of the public
are suspicious of her
but she insists she's just a grieving
mother
i can't grieve in peace i can't grieve
properly at all
i'm being advised to stay home because
it's unsafe
i'm the one hurting the most my baby's
gone
i can't it's hard
she declined to say why she left amari
with rhodes while she was in colorado to
help her mother
but she insists she had no knowledge of
what happened to amari
did you believe tyrell when he said a
woman
came to pick up amari i did
i i had trust in him
and i would have never fathomed
that this would have been the outcome
was there ever a point before his arrest
where you didn't believe him
no not necessarily didn't believe
just started being more aware of
the signs until
on wednesday when we went to metro clark
county district attorney steve wolfson
says investigators have found no
evidence to believe
nicholson committed a crime you don't
believe that she knew
or was lying at this point the
information that's been provided to me
by the authorities is that she didn't
lie
and that although some may question some
of the decisions and judgments she made
that it doesn't rise to the level of
criminal behavior nicholson says she's
planning private arrangements to mourn
the loss of her son
you still see him running around you
still see everything you still hear
everything
and now we just gotta live through what
he loves the most
to keep his spirit close to all of us
and
until then one time we could see him
again
vanessa murphy 8 news now
vanessa also asked the clark county d.a
whether he will seek the death penalty
against terrell rhodes he says it's too
early to know right now he says his
office
is considering attempted murder charges
against rhodes
after police say he fought with police
officers and grabbed an officer's gun
you can watch vanessa's full interview
with amari's mother
at 8newsnow.com